♪ ♪
>> WE ARE GOING TO BE BACK IN
THE GAME.
IT’S NOT A MIRACLE ALONE.
I’VE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK WITH SIX WORLD LEADERS AND
THE RESPONSE HAS BEEN VERY
FULSOME, ENERGETIC.
>> Bret: PRESIDENT-ELECT
JOE BIDEN TALKING ABOUT HIS
INTERACTIONS WITH FOREIGN
LEADERS AS THEY ARE
CONGRATULATING HIM ON HIS
ELECTION.
JOINING US NOW TO TALK ABOUT
FOREIGN POLICY NOW AND IN THE
FUTURE, THE SECRETARY OF STATE
OF THE UNITED STATES,
MIKE POMPEO.
MR. SECRETARY, THANKS FOR THE
TIME.
>> THINKS FOR HAVING ME ON.
>> Bret: WHAT DO YOU SAY TO
WORLD LEADERS WHO ARE REACHING
OUT TO JOE BIDEN, NOW
PRESIDENT-ELECT, LEADERS FROM
ALL KINDS OF COUNTRIES.
BELGIUM, CANADA, ESTONIA,
FRANCE, GERMANY, GREECE, THE
LIST GOES ON, EVEN SAUDI ARABIA
WHICH WAS PRESIDENT TRUMP’S
FIRST STOP.
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO THEM?
>> THERE’S AN AWFUL LOT OF WORK
TO DO.
WE ARE REMINDING EVERYONE THAT
ALL THE VOTES HAVEN’T BEEN
COUNTED.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THE LEGAL
PROCESSES COMPLIED WITH AND
AMERICA WILL DO WHAT IT DOES
BEST.
WE WILL HAVE A LEADER IN THE
WHITE HOUSE AT NOON ON
JANUARY 20 AND WE WILL EXECUTE
AMERICAN FOREIGN POLICY.
PRESIDENT TRUMP WANTS TO MAKE
SURE OUR ENTIRE TEAM DOES ALL
THE WAY THROUGH EVERY DAY.
THAT’S WHAT WE ARE FOCUSED ON.
THAT’S WHAT I HAVE MY TEAM
FOCUSED ON.
THERE’S A LOT GOING ON IN THE
WORLD.
WE ARE PRETTY FOCUSED ERA ON HER
OWN ELECTION.
THERE’S A LOT GOING ON IN THE
WORLD.
>> Bret: YOU ARE ASKED ABOUT
THE CONCERNS ABOUT A SMOOTH
TRANSITION AND YOU SAID THERE
WILL BE A SMOOTH TRANSITION TO A
SECOND TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
WERE YOU BEING SERIOUS?
>> WE WILL HAVE A SMOOTH
TRANSITION AND WE WILL SEE WHAT
PEOPLE ULTIMATELY DECIDED WHEN
THE VOTES HAVE BEEN CAST.
WE HAVE A PROCESS IN THE
CONSTITUTION LAYS OUT HOW
ELECTORS VOTE.
IT’S A DETAILED PROCESS.
NEED TO COMPLY AND I’M VERY
CONFIDENT WE WILL HAVE A GOOD
TRANSITION.
WE WILL MAKE SURE WHOEVER IS IN
OFFICE ON NOON ON JANUARY 20 HAS
ALL THE TOOLS READILY AVAILABLE
SO WE DON’T SKIP A BEAT WITH A
CAPACITY TO KEEP AMERICANS SAFE.
THAT’S WHAT I WAS SPEAKING TO.
I THICKET SUPPORT FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AND THE WHOLE WO
ADVERSARIES.
>> Bret: UNDERSTANDING WE ARE
FOLLOWING THE LEGAL ONGOING’S IN
VARIOUS STATES AND YOU’RE RIGHT,
THE ELECTORS ARE CHOSEN UNTIL
DECEMBER 14.
BUT THERE HAS BEEN A CONCERN IN
THE PAST ABOUT TRANSITIONS THAT
HAVE BEEN DELAYED AND THAT
SOMEHOW ON A NATIONAL SECURITY
FRONT THAT MAKES THE U.S. WEAKER
AT SOME POINT.
DO YOU DISAGREE WITH THAT?
>> I’M NOT WORRIED ABOUT THAT AT
ALL.
I WAS PART OF A POSITION ON THE
OTHER SIDE.
I CAME INTO AN ADMINISTRATION
WHEN I WAS THE CIA DIRECTOR.
WE DID IT VERY EFFICIENTLY.
IT DIDN’T TAKE AS MUCH TIME AS
SOME MIGHT BE PRETENDING THAT
IT’S GOING TO TAKE.
I AM VERY CONFIDENT.
ALL THE THINGS THAT NEED TO BE
DONE WILL BE DONE IN AN
APPROPRIATE WAY.
WE WILL DELIVER THAT.
I WOULDN’T THINK FOR A MOMENT IF
I WAS AN ADVERSARY THAT THIS WAS
THE MOMENT THEY MIGHT HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY.
IT’S NOT THE CASE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND OUR TEAM ARE
ON WATCH.
>> Bret: BACK TO MY FIRST
QUESTION, IS IT IMPROPER FOR
FOREIGN LEADERS TO BE REACHING
OUT TO JOE BIDEN?
>> IF THEY ARE JUST SAYING HI, I
SUPPOSE THAT’S NOT TOO TERRIBLY
DIFFICULT.
MAKE NO MISTAKE.
WE HAVE ONE PRESIDENT, ONE
SECRETARY OF STATE, ONE NATIONAL
SECURITY TEAM AT A TIME.
IT’S APPROPRIATE IT WILL BE THAT
WAY.
ONE OF THE THINGS I HAVE
OBSERVED WITH ALMOST FOUR YEARS
IN MY TIME IN THIS
ADMINISTRATION IS THAT FOLKS
REFUSE TO GET OFF THE STAGE.
THEY TALK ABOUT HEALING INTO
ADDITIONAL THINGS.
I HAVE WATCHED BEN RHODES,
SUSAN RICE AND JOHN KERRY AND
WENDY SHERMAN THE ACTIVE ON THE
WORLD STAGE IN WAYS THAT WEREN’T
CONSISTENT WITH THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION WASN’T DOING.
I REGRET IT WASN’T IN AMERICA’S
BEST INTEREST THAT THEY CHOSE TO
BEHAVE THAT WAY.
>> Bret: FOR ALL THE FOCUS AT
THE BEGINNING OF THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION ON INCOMING
NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISOR
MICHAEL FLYNN AND HIS PHONE
CALLS AND THEY TALK ABOUT THE
LOGAN ACT, ARE YOU WORRIED THAT
THAT IS HAPPENING NOW?
>> I’M ALWAYS WORRIED WHEN
PEOPLE ARE ENGAGING IN
ACTIVITIES, SPEAKING WITH
FOREIGN LEADERS IN A WAY THAT
MIGHT BE REPRESENTING THINGS
THAT AREN’T TRUE OR MIGHT BE
ATTEMPTING TO INFLUENCE AMERICAN
FOREIGN POLICY IN WAYS THAT ARE
INCONSISTENT WITH WHAT THE LAW
REQUIRES.
I KNOW THE LOGAN ACT.
I HOPE THOSE FOLKS OUT THERE
HAVING THESE CONVERSATIONS
AREN’T VIOLATING OUT.
I’M SURE THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE WILL BE KEEPING A GOOD
EYE ON IT FOR US.
>> Bret: FOREIGN POLICY DIDN’T
GET A TON OF COVERAGE IN THE
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
A LITTLE BIT.
WHAT’S YOUR BIGGEST CONCERN WITH
A JOE BIDEN FOREIGN POLICY?
>> I THINK AMERICA’S BIGGEST
CONCERN OUGHT TO BE THAT WE WILL
RETURN TO A POLICY OF
APPEASEMENT.
I THINK THE ADMINISTRATION USED
THE TERM "LEADING FROM BEHIND,"
THE ANTITHESIS OF WHAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS DONE.
WE HAVE BEEN REALISTIC.
MOVING THE EMBASSY TO JERUSALEM
OR TAKING DOWN QASSEM SOLEIMANI
OR REDUCING THE THREAT FROM IRAN
OR RECOGNIZING FOR THE FIRST
TIME IN 40 YEARS THAT THE
CHINESE COMMUNIST PARTY
PRESENTED IN A NORMAL THREAT TO
THE SECURITY OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE AND FRANKLY JOBS AND ARTY
AMERICAN ECONOMY.
I THINK THAT THINGS THAT THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION DID PUT
AMERICANS INTO WORSE PLACE.
I THINK PEOPLE’S JOBS AND LIVES
WERE LESS SECURE THAN THEY HAD
BEEN FOR THESE PAST FOUR YEARS
AND I HOPE THAT A PRESIDENT WHO
COMES INTO OFFICE IN THE MIDDLE
OF JANUARY NEXT YEAR WILL HAVE A
MUCH MORE ROBUST, MARKETABLE,
MORE CONFIDENT NATIONAL SECURITY
APPROACH THAN WHAT THEY HAVE FOR
THOSE EIGHT YEARS.
>> Bret: WHICH IS THE MORE
IMMINENT THREAT?
IRAN, RUSSIA, CHINA?
>> THOSE ARE HARD QUESTIONS TO
ANSWER AND WHEN I THINK ABOUT
THE CHALLENGES THAT AMERICA IS
PRESENTED OVER THE NEXT FIVE OR
TEN YEARS, THE CHINESE COMMUNIST
PARTY IS THE CENTRAL THREAT.
THEY ARE HERE.
THEY ARE INFLUENCING THE WAY WE
THINK ABOUT THE WORLD.
THEY HAVE TECHNOLOGIES THAT ARE
VERY CAPABLE.
THEY HAVE STOLEN INTELLECTUAL
PROPERTY THAT’S DESTROYED
MILLIONS OF JOBS IN PLACES LIKE
KANSAS, IOWA, MICHIGAN.
WE CANNOT LET THAT CONTINUE TO
HAPPEN.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS MADE REAL
PROGRESS GETTING THE WORLD TO
RECOGNIZE THIS THREAT.
>> Bret: SHOULD JOE BIDEN BE
RECEIVING THE PRESIDENTIAL DAILY
BRIEF, THE CLASSIFIED VERSION?
>> I WILL LEAVE THAT TO OTHERS
TO SORT OUT WHETHER IT’S
APPROPRIATE OR NOT.
>> Bret: WHEN YOU SAY IT’S
GOING TO BE A SECOND TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION, THE PRESIDENT
HAS TWEETED OUT THAT THIS IS A
CORRUPT ELECTION, THE DEMOCRATS
ARE TRYING TO STEAL THE ELECTION
FROM HIM.
DOES IT MAKE IT HARDER FOR THE
STATE DEPARTMENT IN DEALING WITH
OTHER COUNTRIES WHERE WE HAVE
TRIED TO SAY TO THEM A
DEMOCRATIC REPUBLIC AND OUR WAY
OF VOTING IS THE WAY TO GO.
>> THAT’S A GREAT QUESTION,
BRET.
I DON’T THINK THAT’S THE CASE AT
ALL.
IN MY TIME WITH THE
STATE DEPARTMENT, WE WORKED HARD
IN COUNTRIES ALL OVER THE WORLD
TO HELP THEM BUILD ELECTION
INFRASTRUCTURE TO MAKE THAT THEY
HAD TRANSPARENCY, TO MAKE SURE
THEY FOLLOW THEIR OWN RULES,
THEIR OWN SYSTEMS.
THAT’S ALL WE ARE ASKING FOR, TO
MAKE SURE WE FOLLOW OUR OWN
RULES, OUR OWN CONSTITUTION, OUR
OWN LAW.
WE HAVE A SYSTEM THAT WE NEED TO
KEEP PRESSING ON AND WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE EVERY VOTE THAT WAS
LEGAL IS COUNTED AND THOSE THAT
MIGHT NOT HAVE BEEN LEGAL AREN’T
COUNTED.
THAT’S WHAT WE ASK IN COUNTRIES
ALL ACROSS THE WORLD.
I THINK THEY SEE IS DOING IT.
I THINK OTHER COUNTRIES REFLECT
ON HOW AMERICA IS PROCEEDING AND
I THINK THEY ARE ENCOURAGED THAT
THE RULE OF LAW IS SOMETHING
THAT MATTERS.
THAT’S WHAT WE ENCOURAGE EVERY
NATION ACROSS THE WORLD TO DO.
>> Bret: SOME PEOPLE WERE
SURPRISED THAT YOUR WEST POINT
CLASSMATE, SECRETARY ESPER, WAS
FIRED.
WERE YOU?
>> MARK IS A GOOD FRIEND AND
MARK HAS SERVED THIS NATION.
WHEN WE WERE CADETS AND HIS TIME
IN UNIFORM, I WISH HIM WELL.
THE PRESIDENT GETS TO CHOOSE THE
FOLKS HE WANTS TO SERVE.
I WILL LEAVE IT THERE OTHER THAN
TO SAY I’M PROUD OF THE WORK
THAT THE ENTIRE TEAM THAT THE
PRESIDENT HAS HAD FOR MY FOUR
YEARS HAS ACCOMPLISHED.
HOPEFULLY WE HAVE MORE TIME TO
CONTINUE TO WORK TO KEEP
AMERICANS SAFE.
>> Bret: YOU FOUGHT TO HAVE
GINA HASPEL AT CIA.
THE FBI DIRECTOR CURRENTLY.
DO YOU THINK THE PRESIDENT IS
GOING TO MAKE CHANGES THERE AS
WELL?
>> I WILL LEAVE THOSE DECISIONS
ABOUT PEOPLE TO THE PRESIDENT.
I’M FOCUSED ON THE MISSION.
I AM FOCUSED ON WORKING WITH THE
TEAM TO MAKE SURE WE DELIVER ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> Bret: OKAY.
LAST THING, 2024.
DO YOU HAVE ASPIRATIONS
POLITICALLY EITHER AT THE
HIGHEST OFFICE IN THE LAND OR A
CERTAIN KANSAS SENATE SEAT THAT
MAY COME OPEN?
>> BRET, YOU KNOW ME BETTER THAN
THAT.
I APPRECIATE YOU ASKING.
I AM FOCUSED ON WHAT I’M DOING
TODAY.
I’LL KEEP AT IT.
>> Bret: MR. SECRETARY, WE